bon c'était donc les prévisions de la
météo nationale mais nous avons souhaité
aussi consulté deux météorologues privé
qui officie tous les deux sur des postes
de radio périphérique albert simon pour
europe 1 et jean breton pour rtl alors
nous allons commencer par ordre
alphabétique par jean breton
alors d'abord phospho expliqué un petit
peu ce phénomène
historiquement c'est un phénomène qui
est vraiment important ce froid général
est toujours difficile de dire que l'on
passe dans un moment historique c'est
très très difficile mais il est vrai
quand même à mon avis en tout cas que
c'est peut-être que nous venons de
traverser qui n'est pas isolé parce que
nous avons déjà connu un printemps
difficile et nous venons nous arrivons
maintenant au septième mois consécutif
de température pour le haut niveau
national de température inférieure à la
normale et de plus le site est
excédentaire
il est vrai qu'actuellement je crois que
se situe à un moment historique je ne
veux pas dire les dix jours que nous
faisons de vie mais dans l'ensemble
c'est une période donc très spécial et
je la classerais donc de cette manière
je dirais qu effectivement il y à un
changement climatique est un
bouleversement climatique qui s'opère
alors évidemment c'est celle à venir qui
en quelque sorte nous permettra de dire
si vraiment c'était c'était le cas parce
que nous sommes pas encore suffisamment
armé pour effectivement vivre
l'événement comme il se devrait mais à
mon avis c'est effectivement un
bouleversement climatique et qui
continuera encore albert simon on peut
dire que tout est pourri en ce moment
non je ne crois pas pas du tout je crois
qu'il ya des années qu'ils sont comme ça
et d'autres qui sont comme ça il faut
regarder en arrière
on peut retrouver par exemple qu'en 1907
il avait neigé en corse le 9 juillet et
et à d'autres années en 1849 faisait 39
degrés le 9 juillet alors voyez ça varie
beaucoup ce sont des fluctuations et je
crois que vous appelez un petit peu trop
table parce que tous à ceux ci avaient
été annoncées déjà depuis trop longtemps
déjà en armes par vous et par vous mais
pas forcément par jean breton jean bâton
j'ai lu de vous une interio qui disait
que la première des karatékas les
premiers jours de juillet porteraient
les meilleurs espoirs on aurait le
maximum
donc effectivement dire alors je
reconnais m'être c'est une fois toute
façon une
une manière effectivement de se
reconnaître que je me suis trompé dans
cette première les cas expliquer cela
s'appelle les extrêmes parce que nous
sommes passés d'une extrémité à l'autre
vous savez quelquefois dans les extrêmes
on se donnerait facilement on a l'amour
on a l'amour ou la haine on peut avoir
les deux et c'est un petit peu comme
c'est un matériau gris parce que 6 à 8
degrés en dessous de la normale ça ne se
prévoit pas forcément facilement
pourquoi parce que tout simplement
par exemple prenons le cas de notre
collègue de la météorologie nationale
qui a bien constaté qu anticyclone était
sur la france
et bien tout le monde a pu constater que
le baromètre pendant le même temps
indiqué beau temps et que justement donc
si on calculait d'après la pression on
eux on devait normalement se trouvait
dans une saison de plus normal quand les
gens voient toral vers ciment vous êtes
là devant des millions de
téléspectateurs vous allez prendre des
paris je sais que c'est un risque car
les gens de la météo on aimera aller au
delà de cinq jours vous allez aller plus
loin et vous allez nous dire d'abord
albert simon quelqu'un va-t-il faire
jusqu'à la fin juillet et bien moi je
vous l'avais dit depuis le 1er janvier
que l'état allait pas être beau et je
les ai répétés plusieurs fois disant
qu'il ne l'ait pas être chaud ça va
continuer leur nom j'avais dit que la
deuxième moitié de l'été allait être
meilleure que la première
par conséquent alors si vous voulez des
prévisions plus détaillées je peux vous
dire qu en juillet là nous allons
tourner vers un temps plus chaud et
orageux dans les prochains jours ou ya
des orages pour le 13 et le 14 juillet
ensuite il faudra y aura une période de
beau temps à la mi juillet ensuite il y
aura de nouveau de la pluie et un temps
plus frais ensuite de nouveau ensoleillé
chine plus et en plus frais c'est-à-dire
vers la fin juillet parlera nom avant ça
avant avant sa grille il ya une période
de temps très frais qui va avoir lieu
entre le 18 et le 25 et le 29 juillet
mamie tempête le 28 juillet que ce qui
est exceptionnel à cette époque de
l'année est les deux derniers jours de
juillet devrait être assez beau et chaud
ensuite mois d'août a le regard intense
mais bien meilleurs qu'en qu'au mois de
juillet surtout dans la première
quinzaine y en a même une vague de
chaleur entre 6 entre 6 et le 10 août
sur une forte vague de chaleur avec des
températures qui pourront atteindre 35 à
36 degrés dans le centre de la france
contre saint-etienne lyon
et puis dans la deuxième quinzaine sur
un temps un peu plus stable mais plus
frais y sera même très frais vers le 29
août
aussi bien la chaleur il ya de grandes
variations de température et ensuite au
mois de septembre mois de septembre cela
le plus beau mois de l'année en bon état
où il ya le moins de vacanciers oui ce
sera le plus beau mois de l'année quand
il fait très chaude sur la cotation vers
le 7 septembre et sur la moitié nord de
la france allons septembre et c'est dans
la dernière décade un troisième décade
du mois de septembre qui fera le plus
beau et là on aura une longue période de
temps sec qui se poursuivra encore au
mois d'octobre
bon je vous signale que j'ai tout noté
j'espère que les téléscripteurs on
notait on va écouter m'a dit en chambre
alors en ce qui me concerne je dirais
d'abord que je n'ai jamais vu un très
bel été bien été assez difficile
j'ai comme vous nous rappeler tout à
l'heure dans cette période cette
première décade mais en fait nous
retombons dans la danse qui était prévu
parce que si vous lisez plus loin ce que
vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure vous
deviez vous constateriez que dans la
deuxième décade de juillet il y avait
justement d'essayer même il y avait il y
avait des perturbations orageuses et
nous arrivons là nous sommes d'accord
avec à quelques à court terme ont
remarqué que ces améliorations que vous
paris a connu aujourd'hui j'ai eu depuis
l'annoncé sur rtl dès hier matin à 7
heures et je pense pas que vous êtes
d'accord avec albert simon qui nous dit
dans un premier temps je vais alors je
vais me garder de faire des prévisions
très détaillées je suis sous les traits
partie aux partisans de la prévision à
longué la longue échéance un moyen est
donc en moyenne et longue échéance mais
avec les réserves suivant je ne tiens
pas trop à localiser les choses on doit
le faire évidemment parce que c'est
normal sans moment des vacances
et puis également un seriez trop dans le
temps perdu en deux et disons que la
deuxième quinzaine de juillet représente
par rapport à cette des premières
décades que nous avons traversé un
certain rattrapage c'est vrai mais il
sera très relatif il l'oeil ne sera
encore que d'un temps vu finalement tout
à fait normale pour la saison est à
peine puisque après les orages ont peur
des rafraîchissements important deuxième
point c'est que considérant la par
rapport à l'hypothèse que j'avançais
tout à l'heure d'un bouleversement
climatique est pas évident que août
permettra de rattraper je ne crois pas à
un véritable rattrapage de l'été parce
que nous sommes le meilleur mais pas
terrible nous ne sommes pas sortis d'une
cette période qui est tout à fait
spéciale et qui a commencé au début de
l'année et quant à un mois de septembre
qui soit leur idéal je ne partage pas
aller pourtant là j'apprécie beaucoup et
neuf femmes version et je voudrais
vraiment me tomber parce que je suis 20
des vacanciers de septembre est bien et
je ne crois pas non plus à la page et
tellement évident
moi des gars comme emeline quelque chose
que j'ai oublié de dire c'est que dans
la deuxième qui est des cas de cette
note deuxième quinzaine de septembre il
y aura une période de pluies diluviennes
je vais vers la côte basque et même moi
je ne sais pas encore hélas les
relations vient entre le printemps l'été
l'automne c'est en général ceux ci
printemps froid et effroi automne froide
et en principe printemps humide a été
humide mais autant de succès là qu'il
peut y avoir une certaine divergence et
un certain rattrapage de mois d'octobre
tout cela n'est pas très optimiste je
vous propose quand même de prendre la
vie du bon côté
malgré tout parce que j ai un petit
cadeau de la rédaction d'antenne 2 c'est
une chanson dont on ne se lasse pas
singin in the rain par jim kelly et
c'est donc sous des trombes d'eau que je
vous donne votre prochain rendez vous
avec la formation 22h40
hervé claude bonsoir